eric chavaroche je suis candidat à
l'élection législative afin de continuer
à défendre comme j'ai toujours fait des
intérêts des habitants de ma région et à
veiller à conserver les traditions
locales témoignage notre patrimoine très
important dans cette résolution la
première si construction et situé entre
la mer une zone urbaine très riche dont
le panel de la population nous permet de
payer pour nos actions et à maintenir un
bel équilibre et participer sereinement
et harmonieusement à son développement
j'ai toujours été très engagé bien
évidemment sous l'étiquette la droite
républicaine j'ai été vigilants et à
l'écouté de mes concitoyens en tant que
chef d'entreprise et connaissant de
travail de mes salariés ont toujours été
une de mes priorités
ensuite j'ai occupé le poste de
président de l'assurance maladie neuro
et président d'une lettre de montpellier
le toujours su malgré les acteurs
économiques politiques et autres de la
vie locale ont mené à bien des actions
je m'engage à travailler à des et
pousse la d'intérêt général au plus près
des habitants
j'ai donc aujourd'hui l'expérience
nécessaire pour endosser le rôle de
député de la première circonscription de
lyon